Hey, what's going on? It's Bill Burr.
It's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday. Monday
morning podcast and ahhh
just checking in on you. I'm just
checking in on you. How's it going?
How's your Thursday? How's your
week? You have an a good time.
I'll dare you getting ready to
eat your fucking face off. Hey,
well here's a good one for you.
You know you're going to eat like
an absolute pig on thanksgiving.
You know you're going to eat all
the leftovers and all that crap.
You know you're going to drink your
face off the wind the Wednesday before
Thanksgiving going out there,
right?
Trying to meet some ladies, right?
Going back to your hometown,
you know you're going to do all of that
crap as I just the wind screen here on
the microphone. Um, you know,
you gotta to do all that Shit.
So why not? Why not before? Why not now?
Just do you do cardio every fucking day?
Giant Salad,
right? You've got a giant salad, but the
protein somewhere in your fucking day,
lunch at dinner. Why don't you do that
right up until thanksgiving, you know,
and right through the
Thanksgiving weekend. Why don't
you just do that every day?
Say I'm going to get on that fucking
motherfucking elliptical and knock out a
half hour.
Why don't you do that instead of eating
yourself into a food coma and then
you're going to have all that sugar,
sugar and salt in you and you know
what you're going to be thinking.
I should work out and all that fucking
stuff is going to be sitting on your
brain. Gone. No, they all
whoa. Working out is hard.
Shit near become enough fat.
Fuck is easy. Yes it is easy.
Anything worth anything where
something in life is difficult?
Um, come on guys. What are we doing
here? Huh? All right. We fat enough.
How much longer, uh, America are
we going to sit here and gloat?
How much poisonous food?
We have more poisonous food than any
other nation on the planet. You know,
how much longer?
It's not even really point.
I think most of it now that I'm starting
to watch these things on nutrition is
how they just had the whole thing upside
down in the whole food pyramid was
created by a guy who didn't
know shit about food,
who went to fucking Italy post World War
Two where they lost to bunch of Goddamn
nerds. Italy lost that. They lined up
with fucking a star over there, right?
Adolph Hitler. Right. They
lined up with him and they lost.
So he went over to a fucking war
torn country, postwar, right?
Everybody was fucking broke.
So everyone was skinny and he equated
it to their fucking diet and started
talking about how you wanted
to do a bunch of carbohydrates,
like these fucking guys who lost the
Goddamn war or not tell you if something
like that, I dunno, I'll post a video. Um,
but all I know is like y'all,
all that stuff is like the devil.
I still cannot get my head around the
fact that I can eat this much meat and to,
I still don't. I think, you know,
okay.
I guess is my mother always said
everything in moderation is she would yell
across the room. Right. Um,
so I guess that's what you want
to do. So I'm, I'm just going to,
I'm going to do what the fuck I always do.
I do a ton of Goddamn cardio when I
stopped beating around five o'clock,
six o'clock and then I
just crushed the waters.
One of the meals is a fucking
salad. That's what I do. All right.
That's so I lose weight.
I don't sit around blaming society or
the fucking industry I'm in, right.
Is I'm eating a fucking candy dapple.
Yeah.
Like a lot of these
fucking people out there
that if just give it in to their sugar,
salt coma and then want you to sit there
and accept their defeat rather than
standing up and giving them a
halftime fucking speech, you know,
grab it and by that back of their hair
and pulling it out of that bowl of
fucking peanut and fucking chocolate m
and m's and getting right in that grill.
Like Bobby Knight used to poke
at him in the chest, you know,
talking to them about their transition
game between one meal to another.
That's what's happening out there, right?
This, this fucking countries getting,
it's getting softer.
It's getting soft.
Everybody's at Goddamn fucking victim.
Everybody has a fucking excuse, right?
And everybody's letting them get away
with it going like now. Now, now, now.
All right.
Yeah.
It's not the potato chips fault.
It's your fault. All right?
You control your hands. Stop telling
your hands to go into the bag.
All right? You wait a head
of lettuce to what you eat.
Those fucking chips.
Like I'm telling you right now,
you'd be a goddamn dream boat.
You know what you got to do?
Quit your fucking crying.
All right, I'm done.
You know what song is in my head when
I want to? I was just talking to,
I'm in the middle of a radio tour
right now promoting my dates in, uh,
Albuquerque and an Arizona.
I didn't know where the hell I'm going
to be in Arizona, Tucson or some shit.
And then I got a Hollywood,
Florida and I have Orlando,
Florida. Well, I will be going
to the Orlando Magic game.
The last team I need to see protein that
I need to see in the state of Florida.
Plus I've seen the Miami hurricanes
and the Florida gators. What's left?
You ask the Florida State Seminoles.
Okay.
You know, in a central Florida
keeps making noise. I got,
I got to go down there
eventually. Right? Um,
okay.
I Dunno. I guess what's left is to
fucking try to swim Lake Okeechobee,
whatever the hell it is,
and try not to get eaten by an alligator
and maybe the python that ate the
fucking alligator. I don't,
I don't pretend to understand
these things. I don't,
I don't try to pretend to
understand what Florida is.
MMM.
But whatever.
I was just in the middle of this radio
tour and I was joking around this fucking
guy that was interviewing me and somehow
we started singing that song. Brandy.
Remember that sound brandy was a fucking
bitch in depth of Buddha do and hippos
say it,
but he sat there,
hit Nona pirate and he
nibbled would commit to her.
That's such a sad song. When you really
listen to the fucking lyrics, it's like,
she sounds like such a nice woman.
Why doesn't she get out of that
fucking bar and stop talking to those?
Okay.
Those, those whalers, whatever
the hell she's talking to,
their job takes them out to sea.
I did one cruise ship in my entire career.
I have never been further
away from anything that I
knew or love to in my life.
You know, people go on cruises to
get rid of their spouse, you know,
when they went through with the
marriage that they didn't want to be in.
And rather than just looking
at everybody just saying,
I don't want to do this and just let
everybody pelt you with the wedding cake.
Next thing you know,
you're laying in your little fucking
cabin on a cruise ship going like,
all right,
so
Allah,
I'll tell him that I'm going
to take a picture of her
and I'll, oh my God, I just,
the shit that people
do happens to guys too.
People fall overboard in those things.
Why am I talking about cruise ships?
I don't even know why.
Oh yeah.
So why would this woman commit to
these fucking people? You know,
they always make it out
like she's the victim.
I think what really happened was I
think brandy didn't want a relationship.
You know?
Maybe that's what it was.
I just feel like for me,
all right,
so I'm 91 days into did not drinking.
I'm in overtime right now.
The movie is wrapped. I'm basically
done with my gigs for this year.
I'm chilling out. I'm getting
into the holiday spirit or Billy,
the baker's going to rear its ugly head.
I think I'm going to make a
blueberry pie this year. You know,
I'm going to deep fry a fucking Turkey,
but my wife won't let me buy the
apparatus. Why can't we just order one?
I Dunno cause it's not as fun.
It's not that sense of
satisfaction knowing that
somebody else made the fucking
Turkey.
What kind of man am I am going to have
somebody else cook my fucking Turkey.
I mean it doesn't that sound borderline
filthy. That's like something.
If you whispered it in a woman zero work,
I mean you didn't have a fucking problem.
Heavy deep fry my Turkey for me.
The fuck did you just say to me?
All right.
Um,
I don't know.
But you know,
I'm getting to this point that I'm
starting to understand like this is weird
balance you have to have when you're
married you have to say exactly what the
fuck you thinking.
You have to be honest with your partner
while totally agreeing with everything
that they say.
I haven't figured it out yet.
You know,
hey me and some friends who go to brunch.
Do you want to go? No. No I don't.
Why? Because it's always
crowded. It's always crowded.
You go down there,
you got to stand there.
Then you standing outside waiting for
them to fucking call your name and then
when they finally call your name,
he's sitting there eating has all these
other people are eyeballing your plate,
breathing down your fucking
neck from across the room.
It's like the food
version of playing golf.
Is there anything worse than playing golf?
And you got that fucking do.
You got those goddamn borderline pros,
a plane right behind you and you just
see them just fucking like 80 yards away.
Like throwing their hands
up like Jesus Christ.
How many fucking attempts do you need?
It's that same kind of pressure.
It's just like it's fucking play through.
Eat through buddy.
You want to sit down and order?
I'll fucking pick my plate up.
I don't know. Somewhere in that I
was being honest with my wife. Yes.
So you know what?
I gotta rise you today.
Don't you like me anymore?
It's like, lady, I married you.
I'm paying all the bills.
Okay.
What more do this whole thing crumbles
over some fucking eggs that I don't want
to go down and get. We got
eggs in the fridge. Sweetheart,
why don't you bring your friends over
here? They'll sit out on the back porch
cause you want to get dressed up.
We want to go out and look cute and have
other women resent us for how cute we
are talking about spit yourself or
they're being cute and so fucking mad at
them.
Um,
yeah.
All right,
so now that I'm back,
I ordered the NHL and the
NBA package as of yesterday.
I watched my first NHL game.
Why at a y yesterday ruins
verse the Anaheim Ducks.
And if you were rooting for the Bruins,
what a fucking stick around.
Yeah,
I know we're really banged up on
that type of thing. But Jesus Christ,
the one problem the Boston Bruins have
had ever since they decided to blow up
the team is we lack that
fucking power forward.
That person that is on the ice that
everybody else has to be like, oh fuck.
Keep your head on a Goddamn swivels.
So and so's out there. Every team,
if you want to compete in the NHL,
you gotta have that.
It's like a fucking great white shark.
Just swimming around.
Everybody's just hoping the thing just
got done eating, you know what I mean?
And you always keeping an eye out.
Where the fuck is that thing? You know,
it was great white sharks. They just, they
just swim so goddamn slowly until POW,
they fucking turn it on.
Next thing you know,
you've got fucking 90 rows of
teeth coming at you, right?
Yeah.
You're all drunk,
swimming naked out to a bully,
whatever the fuck it is you're
doing at the beginning of jaws.
We don't have that ever since we
got rid of Lou Cheech and, uh,
I don't think that those people
come and go out on a limb and say,
those guys are very few and far between.
We got to have our guy,
um, who's our enforcer, I don't even know.
And I looked at the Celtics roster as
I mentioned. It's like I knew every,
everybody on the Celtics and
now I know like three of them,
they got rid of everybody,
but I heard they're playing great and
I believe they have a game tonight.
So I'm going to watch that.
And I also want to say the Bruins
and playing back to back down here.
I think they're playing the kings.
Um,
these are always brutal games. Bruins
always come out here and fucking loose.
I can't believe the king's it took them
so God damn long to win this many games.
All these years.
Everybody comes down here and wants to
just party in Hollywood and try to fuck a
movie star. That's what
everybody's doing, right?
So then they come to the
game all hung over, right.
Smelling like the flavor of the month.
Whoever the fuck they just banged.
And then they go in there and they just
walked through the game and they get
their fucking asses kicked it.
This is what happens every goddamn time,
but at least you can go down to
Anaheim and beat the ducks. Right?
The, the, the, the, the, the
equally injured ducks. But we wait,
we couldn't get it done.
We couldn't get fact that ducks have
won the last eight regular season games
against the Bruins.
They fucking owners.
But t were an original 16,
getting owned by a team that's
made after a Disney kid movie.
How fucking sad is that. I
have no idea. So anyways,
uh,
yeah,
I am just going to keep going
with the streak. I'm not, I'm,
I'm going to get to at least a
hundred days and then see how I feel.
But if I go through the end of the year,
I'll have four solid months that I
didn't drink. So that's like a 30 year,
which for most people would be good.
But if you saw the level
with which I abused alcohol,
just slapping it all over,
all over the room, uh,
I would feel better if that
number was up around six. But, um,
as I've mentioned, I'm turning 50
next year and I'm going to be fucking,
I'm going staying in my fifties.
I'm going to try do anyways.
I might regret telling you guys that I'm
doing that, but I'm telling you if I,
if I can ever get fucking healthy,
I got another injury.
All right. Listen to this.
I did a inside the NFL,
which you can watch this week
on showtime, right? And, um,
not doing this show. I'm having
a great time. Oh, you know,
it was fucking hilarious. I was in the
green room and I walk in it and, uh,
Ray Lewis is there and I start telling
them how I scalped a ticket to go to a
ravens game.
I've told this story before,
I scalped a ticket and I go in and I
sit down. I'm like, Holy Shit, this is,
I could like announce the game from
where I'm sitting. And I'm like,
this is the one of the best scalp tickets.
I have a gun for a great price.
Then all of a sudden the security
guy just goes, excuse me sir. Ah,
I've been sad for about, you know,
half hour. Uh, is that your seat?
Do you have to take it for the echo a
yet? Yeah, it is. And he goes, oh, great.
Could you come out to the aisle for a
second? So I came, I looked at my ticket.
He goes, yeah, that is, you're
a, that is your seat. Um,
where did you get this ticket? And I was
like, hey, scalped it outside. He goes,
okay, I understand. I understand. Can you
just come down the stairs for a second?
So I come down the stairs.
Now there's another security personnel.
There's two security people.
Can you describe the person that you
bought this ticket off of? I'm like,
I don't know. He had a shirt. I don't
know what's going to go. Ah, no,
it's just we just have some questions.
Can you walk down this aisle?
He'd come like underneath.
So now we're underneath the thing and
I find just say to the guy, go look,
can you quit kicking me out of
this stadium 10 feet at a time?
What's going on here? And then the
guy goes, well these were stolen.
Um, these are season tickets and they were
stolen out of one of our season ticket
holders, mailboxes. So, um,
this is a stolen ticket. I
go, oh, so what? Some school?
And they go, no, no, no.
Well we're going to try to see if, uh,
you know, we can get you another ticket,
blah, blah, blah, and they will
get me all the way downstairs.
Now I'm right next to the two,
like the side door. And I go,
can you get me another ticket?
They're like, yeah, unfortunately not.
And then they just kicked me out.
The whole thing was they didn't want me
to flip out and scream and yell in front
everybody. The fucking NFL
is just, it's such cunts.
God forbid there's an issue,
right?
So I'm telling the guys there the story,
they're all laughing.
So I went out and I scalped it.
I actually was so mad that I was getting
kicked out that I said the fucking
scalper was a tall, skinny white dude.
It was actually a short black guy,
and I don't even know why I did that.
I was just so fucking mad.
I didn't want to help anybody out. So I
went back outside scalped another ticket.
I paid even more money. Now I'm sitting
in the lower deck and I said, yeah,
and I go that. And they're all laughing,
listened to the story and go, yeah,
that's the game that it
was against Cleveland.
That was the game with that dude on the
browns ran for like 300 yards and set
the rushing record and all
of a sudden ray Lewis just,
he dropped his head a little bit and
he just starts staring at me and I'm
laughing. I'm going. So man,
that guy put up like 295 yards because
what are you talking about? I go,
Denny, did he run? And then he
goes, then he goes, no, he goes,
that was our guy. I forget. He
said the guy's name. He goes,
he ran for like two 95. And I said, ah,
I'm sorry, my bed that I laugh. I go,
Jesus Christ, dude, you fucking looking
at me. You went all full metal jacket.
And everyone just started laughing.
Do Ray Lewis is like the fucking
coolest guy ever. And he's still like,
if you saw how like hurt he was,
that I would ever suggest that anyone
put up close to 295 yards on a Raven's
defense that he was a part of.
Um,
I got to ask all those guys so many
cool questions. I actually, uh,
I asked Ray Lewis if he had a heart,
you know,
what's it like being one of the great
linebackers of all time watching how these
linebackers, you know, get
to just sort of, I mean,
it's the wide receivers just to kind
of get to skip down the damn field now.
And he goes, oh, he goes, I can't, I
can't, I have hard time watching. He goes,
I've got to take like
blood pressure medicine.
I'm like walking around watching the game.
So anyways,
where uh,
we're in between segments and they
actually did this segment on like how the
guys on defense don't know what
they can and can't get away with.
So they're playing timid and these wide
receivers and quarterbacks and running
backs. So having a field day out
there. So of course boomer is size,
then is siding with the offense and um,
everyone on the show was signed with
[inaudible], that's overpoliced and blah,
blah, blah, blah, blah. So anyways,
so the segment ends and boomers
continue with the conversation. He goes,
did you see what happened to
Aaron Rodgers? And he goes to,
the guy came over and he pay and boomer
walks over and he goes to pick me up and
I don't know why I
should have said boomer.
I saw the play so he goes to pick me up.
But you know when you
go to pick somebody up,
what you do is you pull them in towards
you and you put the pressure of you
lifting them up across their back.
He didn't,
he tried to pick me up from my side and
like crush my rib cage and you just hear
it. I just started. You
just heard something pop on
my right side and he goes,
oh shit. And he put me down any and
I got, I don't know why just go.
I think that was my back and he goes,
really? It sounded like your ribs.
And I knew instantly that he fucked me up.
He,
I don't know what the fuck
he did to my obliques.
It's not like some lifelong shit, you
know what I mean? I'm not a millennial.
I'm not going to sue anybody. This is
just like four days. Epson salt bath.
But like,
I knew immediately fucked me up and
if somehow somebody sends this to him,
I want him to know that when
I sit here it doesn't hurt.
But I drove my car down at,
uh,
in alley yesterday trying to like
beat this traffic and it had all these
potholes. So like the suspension
was rocking back and forth.
So I was going side to side
and I had to use my old bleaks.
I was just going down
the alley going like,
ah, ah, ah, ah,
but I've got, cause I can laugh right now.
It's still feels fine. But uh, yeah, this,
you know, it would have been such
a cooler story if it was Ray Lee,
Ray Lewis who did it to me as opposed
to a quarterback. But here's the deal.
He's still like six,
four and all of those guys have like
fucking gorilla strength and I'm just a
comedian and my baby blue sweater.
Um,
anyways,
so how funny is that?
I actually went on a fucking football
program with ex NFL players. Hey,
came out of there with an injury.
I'm like day to day right now.
I would still start on Sunday.
If we were playing football,
they'd spray it with
something. Um, but anyways,
I had such a great time with
all of those guys and uh,
Ray Lewis, Nate and a boomer, I had
such a great time on that whole thing.
And of course B,
we were all teasing him about his haircut.
I don't know if it made it,
but I said he looked like count Basie
and they were trashing me for being bald
and all of that. It was just
a, I wish I lived in New York.
That's how much fun I had on that show.
Um,
but also I also realize like how little
football I watch when I was on there,
like when I had to pick the teams,
like I had no idea what anybody's doing.
You know, my daughter's crawling, she
starting to stand up at this point.
I mean that alone I could barely pay
attention and I was in the writer's room
and then immediately went down to the
acting gig. So, uh, my apology, I mean,
of all the fucking years for me to
get back on that show, the one year,
I think next year I'm going to
get to watch a lot more. But, uh,
I was sitting there like before I went on
the show, like trying to study up, like,
you know, the day before you finally,
and you know, you're not gonna pass,
but you're just trying to get a
respectable flunking grade. And, uh,
you know,
even after all that studying,
I have no idea what the
fuck's going win it.
I know the eagles and the rams are
doing well as a, the Vikings and,
uh, and even though the Patriots has
72, I never believe in our defense.
I just don't think we get enough pressure
on the fucking quarterback. And, uh,
they seem to be able to do pretty
well against our secondary this year.
So we'll see. I don't know. But anyways,
thank you to everybody over there for
having me on inside the NFL. Please, uh,
watch it. This week, uh,
Nate gave me shit about deflate gate and
I of course took the bait. Once again,
I always take the bait. I should've just
been like, hey man, you know, fucking,
I got five reasons to not get upset
holding up all five fingers for the five
rings we got. And I never thought
to do that. I immediately quit.
Um,
so anyways,
so I did the fucking show and
then immediately I went down to a,
I went right to the airport because
I wanted to see, uh, get onto my fam,
my family over my family bank,
west out west.
You go back east and you go out west and,
uh,
I get to Newark Airport and I'm hungry
and I quickly realized there's no way to
get food in the air. I flew United
in the entire fucking terminal.
When you showed up,
wherever you went to sit down to eat,
if there's any sort of sit down and
eating, you had to be your own waiter.
You had to interact with this fucking
iPad. And the second I sit down,
I'm looking at my face on the screen.
I'm like, what the fuck is this?
So I cover the camera with my
wallet and the lady comes out right.
Do you know how to use it? I'm
like, I'm not a waiter sweetheart.
I don't work at this restaurant. Why
am I being, why don't I'm, you know,
and I was being a dick to
her and everything. Um, in
the end I tipped her in cash.
So I did. I said, listen,
I'm not upset with you.
I'm just upset with his fucking apparatus
here. I like human beings. Okay.
And I don't like this thing,
you know, filming me here.
Cause that's that filming you. It's just
going to take a picture, your ticket.
It's like, what the fuck does Wendy's
give a fuck about what airline?
I'm flying on you gathering information
and you have to sit there and act like
this thing isn't filming me.
They're going to be like white
male looks to be about this.
A old ordered the fried chicken sandwich
and they're gonna use, just take it.
They're just constantly sucking this
fucking information out about you.
So I'm just sit down,
don't scan your fucking ticket.
Um,
they're gonna use all that
information like, oh no, we're
just trying to, you know,
if it's getting too close in your, your,
your plane is boarding and blah, blah,
blah. They're not, that's what they're
doing on one side. But on the other side,
they're figuring out what race, what
sex, what you ordered, where you live,
how you dressed,
all of this fucking information so you
can get bombarded with even more fucking,
uh, you know, I don't know,
even more advertising. However,
if you just committed a
murder and you think that,
you know by them filming you there,
and that's a good alibi than bought
by all means, don't cover it. But, um,
I don't know if the whole thing
is fucking annoying to me.
And next time I go to Newark Airport,
I'm just gonna make sure I eat before
I get there because this guy, oh frack,
this freckled con, he ain't playing
ball. All right. And with that,
let me read some advertising before
the next person calls me here. Um,
ah, look who it is, but up, up,
up me. [inaudible] me on days.
Stop taking my picture on and Ipad
Badu due to me undies. Me undies.
I'm not happy.
I'm fucking mad.
Why am I working for your fucking joint?
Ah, who gives a fuck? I don't know. I
don't even fucking know. I, I'm sorry.
I just tapped out of that thing lately.
I've just been picking words that
don't even, I can't rhyme them joint.
I know fucking work here.
That's my point.
Bring a lady out here to take my order
and explain what the fuck I'm doing.
I'm not a millennial. No, you can't have
my social security number. All right,
me undies. Everybody be on these.
Let me tell you about me undies.
The only underwear that makes for an
amazing gift Biondi is soft, flexible,
like the whore up the
street and three times,
three times softer than cotton
me undies makes the perfect gift.
You know what? They should come out
with the horse muzzle underwear.
You know what I mean? Soft as a horse.
Muzzle muzzle up against your privates.
Me undies makes the perfect gift.
It's the Goddamn holidays this year.
Don't give underwear. Give me undies. Uh,
this holiday season to get your exclusive
20% off the softest underwear and
socks you'll ever wear. Free Shipping
and 100% satisfaction guarantee.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash
bird that's me, undies.com/burn oh,
we look at this.
We only have one more left.
We only got one more left.
Southie everybody me out.
Everyone at some point has wished
they could just have a beer,
wine or liquor delivered.
Well,
someone finally decided to do
something about, well, why stop there?
Why not bring some coke and some weed?
Introducing saucy me now.
Uh,
the alcohol delivery APP saucy or
now delivers your favorite wine,
beer and liquor, right
to you. Do a on demand.
It's Uber for alcohol.
Did you wake up face down,
still wearing the clothes from last
night and have too big a headache,
but you can still reach for the phone
and you want a little hair or the dog
saucy as the APP for you. Now, if
you're in Los Angeles, San Francisco,
Chicago,
San Diego or Sacramento,
you're saucy order will arrive at
your door in 30 minutes or less.
Ready to drink for the rest of us. Saucy.
We'll deliver beer, wine and liquor.
Uh,
yeah.
Wine and lick.
Korto your door.
I don't know what the fuck copy
this is in two days or less.
Nationwide hate guys, get your
Thanksgiving order in. Now,
there are no premiums, no delivery
fees, no running to the store.
If you got the saucy APP,
you've got a fully stocked bar on your
phone and for a limited time you can get
$15 off when you download the
[inaudible] app and enter Promo Code Bar.
That's the saucy APP, spelled s, a,
u c e y.
And enter Promo code bar for $15 off.
Get the saucy app today. Use
Promo Code Bar. All right.
Ah,
AH,
fuck. There you go. See that? I had
to sit up and I was telling my son,
MMM,
oh fuck. I already got a miss call. Okay,
I gotta get back to this radio tour.
All right, that's, that's
the Thursday afternoon.
Just checking in on all that was
30 minutes ago. I think I'm good.
I'm just checking in on your
fucking podcast here. Uh,
what else? I got another
two minutes here, don't I?
I've got another two minutes and somebody
fucking calls me here. Uh, what else?
What else is there to talk about?
Oh,
I'm going to go to my little studio space
and play my drums today for the first
time in like, I think like three weeks
can to see if I remember how to do it.
But I've been hitting the
practice pad pretty hard. Um,
getting back to taking some lessons.
Um, I'm going to be that fucking guy. I,
this is what I want. This one I'm gonna
be able to do on drums. All right?
If I hear it, I want to be able
to play it. And then my technique,
I want not even have to think about it.
And at my forearms,
everything's Nice and relaxed.
Relax, sitting up straight.
Just one of those fucking guys. And
then I can actually see, you know,
if I actually have any sort of
talent for the goddamn instrument,
that is my goal in 2018.
All right.
And that's it.
Okay.
Somebody can be calling me any second
here and I'm gonna have to promote one of
my gigs. Uh, but, but, but, but oh, I know
what I gotta tell you. I'm doing a Gig for
Puerto Rico Ho.
I'm doing Gig for Puerto Rico the Monday
before a Thanksgiving at the laugh
factory down in Long Beach.
Okay.
This is a very important gig because what
happened out there was devastated and
our president just brought paper towels.
That's all that happened.
Let me see if I can get you this
information here. Where is my,
where is my account? I haven't
tweeted that much shall by profile.
I go to the profile, I
scroll down, I scroll down.
It won't let me of course tweets.
How do I find on a click on my picture?
I slide over.
Okay. Here we go. Scrolling
down, scrolling down
bar. Where's the shit that
I tweeted? I don't know.
I'll get you all the information
as far as no way. I'll look up.
I'll look up Corrine's shit here. Hang on
one second. Hang on, hang on, hang out.
I hate just fucking relax.
All right, here we go.
All right. No, Monday,
November 20th a look who's here.
What's up buddy?
What's up buddy? Please don't touch
my laptop. How are you doing? Monday,
November 20th I'm doing a benefit
for the people of Puerto Rico.
Uh, all the information will be on my
website. And here's the next phone call.
All right. I was looking at my
daughter. I almost said to you guys,
I love you guys to death. No, I need to
say, do you guys go after yourselves?
I love my daughter. Did that look at Geo
Cutie. All right, go enjoy the music.
I'll check in on you and
Thursday I'll see you Monday.
[inaudible]
[inaudible] cool.
Well I've,
well
[inaudible] do
[inaudible]
no sad. Go Man. Need you?
Hey,
what's going on?
It's built bar and it is the
Monday morning podcast for Monday,
November 16th, 2009. And, uh,
I'm actually recording this
set a 12 noon on a Sunday.
What do you think about that? How do you
like that for forward fucking thinking?
You liked that?
I anticipated that Monday was coming on
Sunday and I got the fucking thing out
of the way. So right now you're
listening to it and your little cubicle.
Oh my God. He actually got it
done on time. I just so exciting.
If fucking hate my job,
it's fucking nine in the morning.
My boss is a current and I get to listen
to this and act like I'm looking at
spreadsheets.
There you go.
I finally did it every once in awhile
that come through for the people on the
east coast and a,
you might be asking yourself why bill,
why were you so motivated?
I'll tell you why because for some fucking
reason I have been gone. I've been,
I've been going to sleep like a little
old lady this week, you know you have,
but just to get in one of those weird
sleep patterns where a right after the
evening news, you know, you
watch a little bit of jeopardy,
you slip off your loafers.
So you sit there on the Davenport.
Trying to think of some fucking old
people terms here. I don't know.
And I've been going to
bed like at nine 30,
10 and then I've been getting up at
six in the morning like a farmer,
you know, like a farmer. I just said that,
cause I know this farmers out there
will probably listen to this. Okay.
Truly we get up at four in the
morning. You refill. Can you really?
Good for you. What time do you go to bed?
You know, they're all fucking works out,
doesn't it?
I'm speaking of farmers.
I actually saw a food inc this week
because some, a podcast listener.
I wanted to say that real close podcast
listener, a recommended it. And uh,
the classic give and take care
of the Monday morning podcast.
I learn a little thing. You a little
learn a little thing. I say fuck you.
Everybody laughs. Um,
somebody told me to rent that,
that a documentary food inc and let me
tell you, it was very, very interesting.
Very interesting to see where
the food comes from and uh,
what exactly goes on to the food
before the food gets to my table and a,
which is why this morning I want, I got
up so early to go to a farmer's market.
I wanted to go where the, uh, with
the local guys make it, you know,
where they let the chickens run
free before they murder them.
This is a free range chicken.
It had up fucking wonderful seven weeks
on this planet before we stuck it in a
funnel and sliced it throat actually
had video of how they kill the chickens.
That's what they stick them in.
These little, uh, the, the, the,
the down home farmers, the regular old
farmer who hasn't given into the man dude,
um,
they got like a,
you ever see like those fancy Baker's
right as opposed to the blue collar bakers
who got those fat little
thumbs. Um, the fancy Baker's,
when they go to make
one of those, those, uh,
cakes for some fancy fucking douche
bag who's probably a slumlord, right?
You know, when they go to put
the frosting on, you know,
that little fucking reverse
trumpet thing that they use.
Why am I going so far? Look at, do you
remember? You have a seat back in the day,
the original football games when
they're like, Rah Rah, shh. Just by
[inaudible] that little fucking,
that little fucking funnel thing,
it had a handle on it.
I know.
You guys know what I'm talking about
where they have those and they,
they have like the part,
you know the part where you yell
into that's on that would be like,
oh Jesus, how can I explain this picture?
If you had one of those Rah Rah sis,
boom,
buy things right and you wanted to yell
up to the heavens and you fucking cock
and neck back and the thing
was going straight up.
That's the way they have these things.
And they have them in a circle, like,
like 10 silver ones.
And they take these chickens
and [inaudible] and they
fucking stick them in head
first. So they go right down the fucking
funnel and then that little chicken had
sticking out the bottom and they're like
all and then they fucking sliced their
throat and they bleed them out.
That's how they do it on the
regular little farms. That's
how they do it. And uh,
the other ones more industrial once
they don't quite do it that way.
So Watch our food inc,
check it out. Um, you know,
at the end it's a bunch of fucking
dead animals. But uh, I dunno,
I like clean food. Call me crazy.
But I like clean foods. So anyways,
I was supposed to get up,
you know, early this morning,
I've been excited all this
week cause you know me,
I see one little thing that says
a corporation is fucking me over.
And then that becomes my
quest for that week. You know,
it's why I don't talk on my cell phone
anymore. It's why I don't trust banks.
It's why I'm not a Democrat or Republican.
It all comes down to some fucking
video that some fat fuck living in his
mother's basement has made. And I just
take it as law. That's how I do it. Okay.
And,
um,
so the whole week I've been obsessed with
going to the fucking farmer's market.
Every day I've been going,
well going right, we're going.
And finally yesterday my girl couldn't
take anymore. And she's like, yes,
but going, you know, and they get that.
Okay. They get like that fucking uh,
tone in their voice and I was just like,
what I do, she was my immediate thought.
I just turned around and
walked out because, uh,
you can't slap them even though
they deserve it sometimes.
At least she could throw something at him,
you know,
something that's inbetween nerf in
a blunt object. What would that be?
You know, beyond a pillow but
not quite the refrigerator door.
How about a soft covered book isn't that,
and you know, Frisbee it Adam, cause
that might catch the corner in their eye.
What you do is you sort of lob it at him,
you know,
like a Robert Parish foul shot,
half that, not the rainbow,
sort of like a half rainbow, you
know, and it just lands on them.
The fucking meaty part of their
thigh makes that nice slap sound. Um,
anyways. Yeah. So she annoys the shit
out of me. Right? Well again, a got okay.
They typical broad acting like I'm
being a fucking Douche bag. Right.
And what happens this morning?
She's fucking sleeping like boxcar
Willie until like 11 in the morning.
And she clearly told me like fucking
months ago that you have to get over there
early because if you don't
get over there early enough,
there's just gonna be a
bunch of strawberries laying
on the sidewalk, you know,
so she finally gets up, right.
You're finally gets up around,
she's in the other room,
so you have to whisper here.
She finally gets up around fucking 11.
Yeah.
You know, I'll all sleepy. And she's
like, and she knows she fucked up.
She knows it. I know it. The
downstairs neighbor knows it.
Everybody knows she's fucked up. Why did
she fuck up? Because she overslept now.
She fucked up cause she was a Douche
the day before acting like I was
overreacting like that way. We got
a fucking Gal. And what does she do?
She goes out,
she has a couple of pops and next thing
you know she sleeps till fucking 11 all
right. And you'd probably be like, well
bill, why didn't you go in their wake?
Wake her up. Oh, I'll tell you why.
Because she's been breaking my balls
about how I keep going to bed at nine 30
and then I start puttering around like
some war veteran at five in the morning,
this whole fucking week.
So I let her sleep thinking maybe she
get up at night and maybe she get up at
nine 30 maybe 10 at 10 I just said,
you know what? Who gives a fuck?
Yeah.
I haven't eaten corn fed beef for the
law my whole fucking life. You know,
I'm still walking around. I'll do it
for week. Who gives a shit? Right.
Since she wakes up 11 she's
a, Hey Stan. I said, okay God,
he's still gonna go to the fire is bad
again. And I was like, no, no we're not.
She's like, why not? I go, cause
you told me all this shit was uh,
is gone if you don't get there early,
so why do I want to go over there and
now I also like going over there earlier
because I'm a redhead and we live in a
desert and I don't feel like standing out
in the middle of the fucking street
at 11 o'clock in the morning.
Plus the football games are already on.
So then what does she do?
You know, the typical codependent shit.
She keeps trying to get me to go with her.
Well, there's still going to be
some stuff left. They'll have Kale,
they'll have some broccoli.
Yeah. I don't give a shit.
I was going over there for the meat.
That's what, that's what I was doing.
So you can't come with me.
No.
Aaron Sealey can come with me.
That fucking nightmare and
I just refuse to fucking go.
I'd gotten on with my day.
I started paying my bills for Monday.
I was going to do the podcast, I'm
going to go fucking workout. And uh,
of course the second I started this
podcast, who comes walking in the door,
my girl comes walking in and informs
me that there was still plenty of shit
left,
which is still not my fault.
I went by her information that nothing
would be left and for all I know she's
fucking lion. You know, there was plenty
of stuff left. He could have come with me,
asshole. Um, so that's been
my fucking morning. Um,
and I also realized that my fucking
patriots don't play until eight o'clock at
night, which is five o'clock
out here at five 30. So,
so I had nothing better to do.
I decided I'd do a fucking podcast rather
than sitting here doing nothing when
she came home because then she
could have been like, well,
why didn't she come with
me? Um, anyways, uh, let's,
this is the Monday morning podcast.
Did any of that make any fucking sense?
What does that just a classic
boring fucking relationship story?
Did I just bore you for fucking nine
minutes and 33 seconds? Well, I hope you,
I hope I did because I been getting
too many complaints about the fucking
podcast lately. I liked it back in
the day. You are more angrier, Bill,
do it on your cell phone again.
You know whoever's wrote me that,
you know, what did you use to do?
Why don't you go do that?
Why don't you stop evolving as a fucking
human being and just do it the way you
did it two years ago where the same
fucking shirt. You know what I mean?
You want it the exact same way.
Every fuck enough.
Hey fucking idiots, dude.
I like the new stuff.
I like their first two albums.
I don't like that.
I don't like when they changed and you're
like, people were into bands like that,
like people were into like
fucking youtube. You know?
People just can't fucking respect for
the fact that that they've continued to
fucking evolve and put out
killer songs changed their sound,
come back to their sound,
divert from it become huge.
Rockstars mock being huge.
Rock stars always coming up with a new
way to make it a little bit different.
There always has to be that fucking
douchebag going. I liked it back.
I only liked him.
I liked him up until war or
boy or whatever the name of
their fucking albums are.
I don't even remember.
I remember that one that had that
fucking creepy looking kid, you know,
looks like the poster for the grudge
like 20 years before it fucking came out.
Like there's always people like that.
Yeah.
Granted there are bands that evolve and
then they suck like Jefferson airplane
when they became Jefferson Star ship.
But I,
I challenge you to find anything in the
u two catalog that comes anywhere near
sucking to the level of,
we built this city on rock and roll.
That is one of the worst.
Okay.
Everything,
you know that they like when they show
some of the worst dictators and I'm
really trying to avoid you say
Adolf Hitler because he becomes,
he's become like the hacky reference
when you talk about evil, you know,
and I really think that that guy is a,
and a lot of ways overrated when you look
at is number of kills verse Stalin's.
Okay. I've talked about this before.
Stalin has 20 million confirmed kills.
Okay.
That's fucking like what?
14 million more.
14 million more than Hitler
and about fucking 19 million.
900,000
more than fucking Rambo.
Okay. Um, I'm, you know what? I'm
good. That's my, that's my thing.
That's what that's going
to be my contribution to
conversation in fucking dinner
parties. You know, I'm going to
start going to those, by the way,
I'm going to get a smoking jacket and
all that. And then when people go like,
oh my God, he's like the next Hitler
and I mean, now he's the next styling.
Yeah.
Who is that? I don't know who the fuck
that. Of course you don't get dumb. Fuck.
You probably know. You know
what Hitler did. Do you,
are you just sputtering fucking
spout in the shit out the way?
I do every week on the podcast. You
dumb fuck I'm speaking of which this is,
this is a new part of the
podcast. It's, it's as the bills,
dumb bill's dumped quote of the week.
Um,
I had a bunch of people,
um,
correct me on something that I have been
saying for years. I used the expression,
I said for all extensive purposes and
somebody wrote for all extensive purposes.
It's not,
um,
you don't say it that way and you don't
say it the way most other people say all
intensive purposes.
It's actually for all intents and purposes
you like that most people say for all
intensive purposes when they fuck it up,
Bill Burr took it to a whole new level
of stupid and said for all extensive
purposes.
Yeah,
I do that all the time. I
say there's something else
I say it has to do with, ah,
what the fuck is it the beginning of
your college year when you're a freshman?
Ah, Jeez. My memory is just fucking shot.
I used to always work those things
as a stand up comic. He'd come in,
it'd be like the first, ah, why
do I keep thinking salutation?
That's not what it is.
I know it begins with an s though.
Oh,
this happens to me like 20 times a day.
Is it some sort of fish that I can
be eating to help me with this?
I used to do the gigs every year,
the beginning of the year and coming
freshman gigs. You'd come in and they,
we sit in there with their parents and
my college age, it'll be like, uh, uh,
Billy we got, uh, we got,
I got a Gig for, yeah,
the parents are going to be there
so it makes sure you don't say fuck
God damn it. I forget.
But whatever I used to,
I used to fuck that word up
all the time. Um, so whatever.
So I learned something.
It's for all intents and purposes,
I used to say Pelo instead of pillow,
p. E. L. L. O, I'm a fucking moron.
And I don't know why you guys,
you know what? You assholes.
I know why you listen to me. You listen
to me because my level of stupidity,
he makes you feel better about
yourself, doesn't it? Huh?
What does that say about you?
You fucking whores.
See how I got out of that by trying
to blame you. That's, that's it.
That's a technique I use in my arguing.
Um, but it hasn't, it wasn't all bad.
I actually got, I got some thanks
last week from a, from a hormone.
It said Bill. Um, you were
wondering if there are any, ah,
Jesus Christ.
I fucking,
I copied and pasted the wrong
one here. This isn't from
a woman. Listen, this bill,
uh,
you were wondering if there were,
there are any Jews that
listened to your podcast.
There are Jews who listened to your
podcast. I am one of them. And in fact,
an Orthodox Jew. I'm not
Hasidic, I'm not a Hasidic Jew,
but it's the same thing without
the curls. Dude, that's bullshit.
There's got to be something more than
that. I know you just made a joke there.
What is the difference between an
Orthodox Jew and a Hasidic Jew? I know.
I could fucking
Google that right now and get
some other morons. Fucking not,
I'm not saying you're a moron,
you know what I mean?
Just get some morons
version of what that is. Um,
what was the name of that place I used
to go to down on ninth avenue and it was
a best electronic store, uh,
and fucking New York Jr's,
something like that.
It was like a block over from Madison
Square Garden at where are they now?
Those guys or those guys?
Orthodox Jews are they Hasidic Jews?
I don't know what they were,
but they were the shit.
They knew about everything and uh,
they had great prices and they weren't
open on Sundays and I respected that.
You know,
somebody still doing it.
The little house on the prairie
way observing the sabbath.
That's one of the worst things that
we've done as a culture as far as getting
away from religion is we got,
we got away from a fucking day off.
You know, this is how old I am. I remember
when fucking malls and all that shit,
we're closed on Sundays.
You buy liquor.
Is that still true? Can you still
not by luck, he couldn't buy bear.
You couldn't fucking do anything.
He just had to sit there and think about
why God was going to send you to hell,
you know?
But at least you weren't working.
Do you guys remember that little house
in the prairie episode where fucking, uh,
uh,
Michael Landon was busting his ass all
week and then they had to go to church on
Sunday and he was so fucking tardy,
fell asleep in his church clothes.
And the mother looked at him
and he's like, should I wake
them up? And she's like,
God, no, he's sleeping like an angel. God
wouldn't want me to bring them to church.
He eat. He should. This is a day of rest.
He's resting like the Lord after
six days of creating a universe.
So the bitch goes to church,
she goes to church,
and when she comes back,
this asshole woke up from his little
slumber and he was outside with an ox and
he was plowing the fields again
and all did she get mad at him?
She really got mad at
him. And, uh, then that,
that little girl is skipped down the hill
and she fell into some shrubs and that
was the end of it. And that was another
episode of Little House on the prairie.
Let's continue on with the
orthodox Jewish person's email.
Cause last week I was talking
about a beanie. Is that,
is that offensive or whatever he said,
I wanted to let you know that there
is essentially the Yamaka. Um,
and yes, there is an r in there. Um,
but it's sort of silent is a
skullcap as opposed to a beanie,
which you were sort of confused about.
Sort of confused.
You'd be in Nice here I'm
calling it a beanie. Uh,
should not insult anyone.
It's almost the same thing.
What is the pope were technically,
it's called a,
I can't even read what the w Z.
Kevo. Zee you see c. H. E. T. T.
O m also means skullcap.
Um,
the real meaning of the
Yamaka is Yar fear of Maca.
The king and exciting signifies that
there is someone up above and that we are
limited moral beings. Well,
what do you mean it's sick?
Okay.
Yeah.
Doesn't it really signify that there's
someone above that you should be scared?
Shit of and that we're limited debts.
Easy.
That's the thing that I never liked about
organized religion is the bully factor.
I can, it's just like, why is this
guy, how is God already mad at me?
I'm six years old.
You know what I mean?
It just created like if you
believe in this higher power,
it's just fucking angry. Douchebag always
looking down at you. Pissed off at you.
You know what I mean? Why are you
fucking mad at me? You made me,
you know what I mean? If I fucking built
a car from ground up and it didn't run,
didn't run correctly,
who the fuck am I going to blame the car?
That doesn't make any sense.
Did what I just say make any sense?
I don't fucking know where I
like to just finish this. Um,
also you mentioned how the guy on the
plane was wearing a Yamaka so big.
You weren't sure if it was a hat
or some sort of giant Yamaka.
I totally agree with you.
I wear a normal size Yamaka and am a
little annoyed even when someone wears one
so big that it covers their whole head
almost like a hat, but to each his own,
I guess.
Um, anyways, a big fan of your
comedy and your podcasts. Uh,
well thank you for listening. I
appreciate that. You know what?
I actually have a theory on
those big time. Yamakas I
think that that is the, uh,
that's the poor man's toupee after a
while because if you're going bald in the
back, you start to lose
it in the back like I am.
I'm a Yamaka is great because at buys
you another three years of people not
knowing that you're losing your hair.
Okay.
See,
a lot of people don't realize that Sammy
Davis Jr was actually losing a little
bit of his Afro and that's
why he converted to Judaism.
A lot of people thought it was a, it
was a show business move, but it wasn't,
he was going bald. You're
here to, you heard it here
first. So now I'm fascinated.
What is the difference between an
Orthodox Jewish person in a Hasidic Jew?
What is the difference? And also,
do you believe in an afterlife?
Do you believe that God is mad at you?
What are the Catholic Shit that I learned?
Um,
can you eat a cheeseburger on Friday?
Yeah.
And I know like all religions,
you consider yourselves 100% right?
And the chosen ones, do you guys have
the Notre Dame? God loves us best.
You know, do you have that to that
disease that is in every fucking religion?
You shouldn't kill anyone,
but God loves us the best.
And anyone who doesn't believe what
we believe, it's going to hell.
Have a great week everybody.
Be sure to pass that on to
people who don't believe in us.
Why does every character my
fucking act talk like that?
Yeah.
What did the priests used to sound
like at my church? Hey, how you doing?
Hey look, I'm pretty good in that outfit.
Go ahead. Lifted up a little bit. Um,
thank you. That was my impression
of a Catholic priest. All right.
I've been doing a lot of ranting and
raving on this podcast. People, um,
talking about those little save,
you know,
those little scan cards
at the grocery store.
And somebody told me that what you're
actually doing is taking a survey and a,
you know,
to help them figure out what products
you can't live without so they can jack
the price up.
And I've actually taken that as law.
So this is somebody I've had
a bunch of different theories.
There's another theory.
Um,
a couple of weeks ago you brought up the,
uh,
Saber cards at the store and is wondering
what the purpose of you are wondering
what the purpose of them was.
Um,
you speculated that it was so they knew
what you were buying to jack up the
prices. But with the Bard
Chords, Barre chords scanning,
they already know how much inventory they
move and what sells better than other
things. The purpose of the car
is to gather your information,
to sell it to mailing lists,
who then send you junk mail
or spam. Since they always
ask for an email address,
they also can be used as an incentive to
keep you going to the store instead of
a competitor. I, he going to
Macy's instead of JC penny's. Uh,
they give you the discount without the
cart occasionally so you can be learned
into saving 10% or so every time you go
there so they can eventually get your
information. Um, hey, your guests good
as mine. I don't know what they're up to,
but I also noticed that most of the shit
that's on sale is there bootleg version
of the real shit. You know what
I mean? Like Ralph's olive oil,
you know, I've noticed that,
uh, that's another great
way. Like they could be like,
okay, we're selling the food.
What if we made it also, you know,
and had our own fucking farms.
I Dunno. I just don't like,
I don't trust people who are going out
of their way to give me a fucking break.
I don't,
you know what I mean?
Yeah.
That's like the fucking
Andrew Carnegie kind of like,
yeah,
when you're doing shit, you know,
you fuck people over your whole life.
And then the NTL life,
you're worried that maybe really
there is a god and then you become a
philanthropist and you start
giving you shit away. Fuck you.
You sit there with your guilt.
I'll pay full price for the peanut butter.
Thank you very much. All
right, another theory.
Um, uh, what the fuck is this one?
This guy says I'm a software engineer
who finished working for a company that
stores and reports on all
sorts of insane sales data.
Some examples of that type of data.
They can gather a sales of
products based on ethnicity. Yeah.
See this is why I think they also want
the car cause it's not enough to know all
we sold 20 boxes of fruit loops.
They want to know was it a guy,
was it a fucking girl? How
old were they? What color?
Um, the main data I saw on this kind
was defined as Hispanic or non Hispanic.
And I guess that's sales
based on ethnicity. Um,
this is a guy who gathers this data.
I guess he says if there is a
floor display in some store,
what is the effect on the sales
of the item while it the display
what
I'm the worst?
If there was a floor display in the store,
what is the effect on sales of that
item while the display is present?
Let's say for example, there was a
NASCAR event sponsored by Coca Cola.
They keep track of coke sales in that
region around the time of that event.
Furthermore, they analyze if the cost
of sponsoring this event made it,
that made them enough money to profit
to make it worthwhile sponsoring similar
events.
This is just a small portion of wacky
shit that they update weekly that was
written in capital letters weekly. I
guess that's important. Weekly. Um,
they know every single damn item that
was moved out of each and every store
every single week.
So basically the stores with the savvy,
the savvy saved cards
get two huge benefits.
They sell this data to my old company
to make money and they let the consumer
feel as they got,
they have some kind of superhuman power
to save 40 cents when they buy three
gallons of milk in one visit.
So there you go.
I don't know you're helping
them gather information.
I don't like the fucking pricks
so I'm not using one. Um,
all right, now let's get to the meat
of the podcast here. People, shall we,
I'm doing this on a football fucking
Sunday right now cause I could give a shit
about other teams in a league right now.
All I give a fuck about
right now is my patriots.
And it's basically because I've watched
so much fucking hockey this week that
I'm kind of all, I'm done
with sports. I watched,
I was flipping back and
forth between the Ohio state,
Iowa Hawkeyes game this week.
And I was also flipping back between
that and the USC Stanford Game and Jesus
Christ.
How about a moment of silence for the
fucking fans of the USC Trojans who went
out to see that? I mean that
was our fucking ass rape.
And you guys took, you know,
and I'll tell you right now,
Trojan fans,
you have no fucking right getting mad
at Jim Harbaugh for going for two point,
let me, let me, let
me, let me set this up.
Basically Stanford was up 48 to 21 for
those of you overseas usually just kick
an extra point,
right to make it 49 or you can
go for a two point in version.
There's no reason to go for a two point
conversion when there's six minutes left
and you're up by four or five scores and
they went for it and the crowd started
bowing and um,
you know,
you got gotta understand you
guys USC for the last five years,
you have been raping everyone in the
pack 10 you're bent him over you, I mean,
how many times did you guys score a 50
60 points sent the other team crying on
that little team bus, send
them home crying, right?
Well what goes around comes around.
And a,
I became a huge Stanford
and Jim Harbaugh Fan,
but the fact that he went for two
points and then he also, in the end,
they got the ball back again
and he went for the end zone.
The end up winning 55 to 21.
Jim Harbaugh was trying to literally
end the football program at USC.
Uh,
it was one of the most vengeful back,
the biggest acts of vengeance
I've seen in sports in awhile.
I fucking loved every second of it.
Um,
and I was also watching the, uh,
the Osu, uh, Iowa Hawkeyes game.
And those are the fans of the podcast
know that my new tradition is I go to the
rose bowl every year. So both
of those games were huge. I was,
I know I really didn't want to see
USC again. Mainly because, you know,
I like variety. And that fat cunt from
La last year's game was a USC fan,
so I'm happy that she had a miserable day.
You know,
she probably didn't know
100%. She probably, you know,
I had a dozen donuts in front of her,
so it wasn't a total loss. Really. Bill,
11 months later, you're still giving a
shit about our weight. Yeah, I am. Um,
and then Iowa, you know that
fucking quarterback for Iowa,
that kid's 19 years old.
I'll tell you all you
longhorn fan sitting there
talking about that Colt Mccoy,
that kid at Iowa's was,
those are the fucking plays.
Those are the passes you have to make
to make it onto the fucking pros.
All right?
You have to throw the same kind of
throws that they throw at the NFL level.
You can't be running the fucking option
and gain in like 150 yards a game and
then also throwing for 200 no one gives
a fuck the second you start running.
Watch Tim Teebo watch that guy.
When he goes into the draft,
that guy is going to be like,
I sweat if he goes in the second round,
it's not going to surprise me.
He's a tight end playing fucking,
you're not getting that Jesus Freak.
I don't give a fuck how many psalms he
writes underneath his fucking eyes is
going to get laid out and the pro level,
he's going to get fucking laid out.
I guarantee that's my prediction.
All right.
And they're gonna make them a flanker.
They're going to bring back that position.
Um, so anyway, so I did that.
I watched the,
uh,
and then I watched the flyers in the
sabers and I watched the Bruins and the
penguins game. Um, actually watch
the penguins game this morning.
I want you to fucking recording of
it. So I'm all, I got nothing left.
I can't watch any more fucking sports,
but I have to watch the patriots tonight,
play a con face Magoo and
the Indianapolis Colts.
Um,
and I really hope to patriots win
because I really want to hear how Peyton
manning is going to figure out how to
complain about Bill Belichick and the
Patriots this year.
That guy's one of the biggest fucking
babies in the history of the NFL.
One of the biggest crybabies in
the history, uh, the fucking NFL
they were holding on you
are receivers and night.
I couldn't get to Paul to them.
I remember that year he cried
about it after the game,
he made a tape. Three weeks later
at the pro bowl, he cried about it.
He quiet about it all the
way to the draft. Now,
if you're ever watching the NFL and you're
wondering why is it illegal to cover
receivers now it's because
of Peyton manning whining.
He wore a diaper from fucking January
until may crying about this fucking game.
Hey,
whoa.
[inaudible] fell like a jerk.
Yeah.
And then what happens?
They make this rule where basically you
can't cover a receiver and the very next
year he goes out. Not only does he
break Dan Marino's touchdown record,
he shatters it. A record that had
been around for 20 years. You know,
I'd been around for 20 years.
I'll tell you why.
Because you could cover receivers
and Dan Marino was the shit.
That's why Dan Marino owns every
fucking passing record out there,
except Brett Farve decided to
play till he was 50 you know,
Jesus Christ. If Dan Marino
play til he was 50 you never,
you never want to see and you
couldn't cover receivers that gay.
What a fucking throw 90 touchdowns.
And I hated the Guy Patriots Fan.
He used to kill us all the time and
people still give the guys shit cause he
never won a super bowl.
What was he supposed to do?
Tackle people to you fucking morons.
The guy never had a running back.
Dan Marino is the greatest quarterback
that ever fucking played the game.
The guy was a beast. Second Year in the
league, he throws for like 5,000 yards.
Who does that? Nobody.
Nobody does that. Okay.
So this half retarded
Frankenstein is coming in as
big Frankenstein fucking head.
He's coming in at a play the Patriots
today and I dunno what's going to happen.
You know what's great is I'm recording
this before the game happened.
So I gotta I gotta talk some Shit here.
What I think's going to happen,
I actually think the cults are gonna win.
I think the Patriots' defense is still,
it's too new.
It's too young.
And even though bill Belicheck
is a defensive genius and
he slowly molding them
into that suffocating,
quote unquote boring defense that we had.
Remember that the beginning of the
two thousands when everybody said the
Patriots were a boring
team with no stars on it.
And I take Peyton manning over fucking
Tom Brady wants to score three Superbowls
to one. Really? You'd rather have fucking
one title rather than three. Well,
good luck to you. So, um, I dunno,
I dunno what's going to happen
today, but, uh, I have faith,
I have faith in my boys and I think we're
gonna fucking now we're going to eke
out a victory and I think fucking Peyton
manning is going to cry about it and
he's going to throw his
team under the bus. We Hash,
we have some protection issues. We had
protection. Your shoosh fucking what?
A douche bag.
You know what I mean?
They should go have a sword fight with
that fucking idiot kicker. His, alright,
there you go.
That's my prediction.
Um, anyways, was there a
prediction in there? Yeah, I'm,
I'm my heart saying my heart is saying
that the Patriots are going to win by
three. My brain is telling me that we
might lose by seven just because, um,
I just, I, like I said,
we have a brand new fucking defense
and it's going to take them,
believe it or not,
it does take a good year or two for guys
to get used to each other to know where
they're going to be at,
you know,
to know where you got help and
all that type of shit. So anyways,
let's continue on with the
podcast. Oh, let's get into this.
Shitstorm last week I did a,
uh,
somebody asked me a question about
why when a guy does something,
um, for his girlfriend, why is
it never enough? And one of the,
one of the problems that I've had and
that this guy had last week as you,
you try to plan something that both you
and your girlfriend can enjoy as your
night out.
And evidently women have a problem when
you pick something for the both of you
to do that.
You as a guy will also enjoy
evidently from what I'm reading from these
fucking psycho emails that I got this
week,
is that if it's not 100% about them,
if you don't literally make
a rose bowl fucking float,
set them on it and then drag it down
the street with your fucking teeth.
They feel that you got too much
and enjoyment out of the evening.
So basically the evening was there.
It was really your evening.
It was re look at the fucking wedding day.
You stand in a like an idiot and
she makes this grand entrance.
She gets some one of a kind dress and you,
you get a Tuxedo that some fucking drunks
gonna wear at a 15 year anniversary
for a bowling alley the next fucking
week. You know what I mean? All right,
let's listen to what the twats had
to say to this week. Um, all right,
here is this, this, this wonderful girl.
And I said she's wonderful because she
actually admitted that she was a psycho
because I actually emailed her and asked
her, why do you only respond to male,
female shit? And she sort of
in her own little cute way,
admitted that she was a psycho.
So I can't hate her. But anyways,
this is her email.
Hey Bill,
I love the clueless email
questions from your male listeners.
That's always a great way,
by the way,
to get the other people to listen to what
you have to say right out of the gate.
Just start insulting them and talking
down to them. Um, he said, uh,
the guy was asking, why is it never enough
to please a woman since he admit he?
Um, and then she's referring
to his email. He, she says,
since he admits he isn't home a lot,
I'm guessing his wife slash girlfriend
is doing all the dirty work for him,
his laundry, cleaning, cooking, picking
up after him, et Cetera. All right,
let's stop right there.
She's doing all the dirty work.
Let me ask you guys a question.
Would you rather sit home doing laundry?
First of all,
laundry is the most
overrated fucking chore ever.
If you have laundry in
your fucking apartment,
what that takes all of a minute
to load the fucking thing in.
And if you're not colorblind,
it probably takes 45 seconds to load it
in and then you go back to watching the
prices. Right? Cleaning,
cooking, picking up after him.
I would rather do that than do
what this other guy's doing.
This other guy is working like
60 hours a fucking week. Okay,
let's, let's move it. She's already
made this assumption. Okay. Then she,
then she wants him to spend some,
set some time with him and he comes up
with something that he wanted to do.
Just like when you took your
girlfriend on that drive,
all we heard about was the love
story between you and the car.
You were more excited about
the car than anything.
It was like you were on a date with the
car and your girlfriend just came along
for the ride.
Listen back to even the tone in your
voice when you were talking about it.
It's like you were talking about another
woman. All right. You know something.
I could sit around for 20 years trying
to come up with the perfect paragraph to
talk how insanely jealous and
psychotic women are. Can you,
they are the jealous about an inanimate
object. She's talking about a car.
It's almost like you are talking
about another woman lady.
You are out of your fucking mind.
You're out of your fucking mind and you're
totally ignoring the fact that I took
her out to dinner,
I took her out to lunch,
I took her up for a ride up
to Pacific coast highway.
People fly out here as
a vacation to do that.
A lot of couples do that
and I'll tell you right now,
they don't do it in a
corvette convertible.
They do it in like a fucking
whatever our Buick century.
Really,
I mean it literally is never enough.
You're actually proving this guy
point this guy's points as she says,
my husband does the same damn thing.
I'm like,
what can we do for fun
today slash tonight?
And the only thing he can come up with
are things that interest him. Well,
what can you come up with?
Can you come up with anything
that doesn't interest yourself?
You're selfish cunt.
You're doing the exact same fucking thing.
And it's unbelievably selfish for you
to sit here and, and, and have like a,
a day that's for both of you and it has
to be 100% about you because what you
did, some laundry, you lazy. Fuck
your base. You know what women are,
they're basically, they're like
adult children. That's what they are.
They never get beyond their,
like juveniles.
They're adults, but they still want to
be treated like they're not of age. It's,
it's just fucking boggles my goddamn mind.
Um,
she goes,
I'd rather not do anything at all.
I think itself is an egg nog and obnoxious
that everything we do has to have his
interests before mine.
So everything that they do should
have your interests before his,
you're right. Yeah. He's, he's fucking
broad. So right at the seat, this is,
this is my thing. This is why you
should, you should never get married.
You should never be in
a fucking relationship.
You shouldn't because they just
constantly fucking hack away,
itch a goddamn knees.
And their idea of a relationship is that
you do everything that they want to do.
And right now they're sitting there
shaking their heads, they're going now.
Now even the girl wrote,
that's probably saying no.
And then there's a bunch of other
women going like, I'm not like that.
And I like that.
I went to a ping pong convention.
They always come up with some
stupid ass fucking example.
And at the end of the fucking day,
you have to do everything that they do.
The you have to do what the fuck they
want to do or else they get mad. Okay.
And that my friend is when jerking off
comes into play because when you really
break it down, what's the worst thing
that they're going to do to you?
They're not going to fuck
you for a few days. Okay.
And I gotta be honest with you, once
you rub one out, who gives a fuck?
And you have to have that clarity
when you're nuts are full.
Do you know what I mean? Am I sounding
like a fucking maniac here? I know I am.
I know I am. But you got, you got to hear
what the, what this, what this other,
this other woman wrote.
And of course I don't have it in front
of me because I'm an idiot with a fuck it
is it all right.
Um,
I am writing to comment on the wide has
never enough discussion on your last
episode episode. I'll start
by saying that the, that wrote
in and to a slightly lesser extent,
you come off as total Douche is,
let me explain my view of the writers,
the writers situation. Oh, I guess
the guy sent the email. Uh, and yes,
I am one of those manipulative,
selfish creatures known as women. Um,
yeah,
you are what you call yourself out on it.
Now Suppose Oren was I supposed to
like read that and be like, Whoa,
I really am too harsh on women.
Say you're like trying to manipulate me
with your fucking bullshit already. Okay,
here we go. Um, I don't
remember the names,
so I'll call him Bob and his wife Sally.
Bob Neglect Sally.
A huge fuck up on Bob's part.
Now let's, let's get back to the,
to the detail here. He's
neglecting her. What does he,
is he out at the bar chasing other women?
This guy is out working
his fucking ass off.
This is the thing that
women don't understand. What
they don't understand is I,
this is maybe I'm being a more on,
again, are a Douche as this lady says.
I think a lot of women don't understand
what it takes to be successful.
What it takes is sacrifice and in your
20s you have to work your fucking ass off.
That's what I did for five years with
my first five years in this fucking
business. I had no girlfriend. I
had no social life and nothing.
All I was doing shows and
and fucking rubbing one out.
That's what the fuck I did.
Every God damn day I went to work.
I was writing jokes at work and at
night I got an a piece of shit car and I
would sometimes drive to another
fucking state and you know why I had no
girlfriend during that time because none
of them could understand what I had to
do to get where I am today.
All of them were giving me shit.
You're doing fan of again tonight.
Do you realize how many Richard Pryor's
are fucking working at a home depot or
Jimi Hendrix because they hooked up with
the wrong fucking Twat who talked him
out of their goddamn dream
because they didn't want,
they didn't want to hear it because
they said you needed some sort of
responsibility.
This fucking guy is doing the right
thing and she's calling him selfish.
He's at work busting his ass trying
to get ahead. So when he's 40,
he's not a fucking loser and he has,
let's see.
And they all want the fucking house.
They all wanted fucking yesterday,
but they don't want to get
through the bullshit of it.
They don't want to go through the bullshit
of it where you actually have to, uh,
not see him for a little while
cause he's out working. So anyways,
huge fuck up in his fart part to be a
busting his goddamn ass. So he says,
Bob Decides to make it up to her by taking
her to see your live show, she says,
which is awesome. And a dinner,
which is pretty standard.
This is how out of control women are.
She's getting a free fucking meal and
they're so spoiled as a sex that she's
describes a three
fucking meal as standard.
Do you know what I have to do
as a man to get a free meal?
I have to like when like a fucking,
like a radio contest,
you know,
I got to call up this radio station and
imitate the local sports guy and I have
to beat out all these other
fucking guys who are, uh,
I haven't had a free meal since I was
like eight years old and my parents took
me to Mcdonald's or whatever.
Like maybe 13,
14 women are so fucking spoiled that this
guy is busting his ass at work that's
viewed as selfish.
He's buying this girl a free
dinner and it's viewed as standard.
They're out of their fucking
mind. So anyway, she goes,
Sally basically tells her friends who
may or may not know that Bob has been
fucking up. Once again, Bob is fucking
up because he's busting his ass at work.
So when they're 40, they're going to be
uneasy street. He's fucking up right now.
Um, the same bitches who make you
fucking, you know, not chase your dream,
leave you when you're 38 because you're
a fucking loser. Right? All right.
I love generalizing. It really gets
these twats can hairs in a fucking,
I didn't want to, I can't even finish that
sentence. That was so evil. All right,
let's, let's plow ahead. Um,
who may or may not know that Bob has been
fucking up that this night out is not
what she had in mind,
but she is taking what she can get
playing the victim are the poor baby.
She's taking what?
She got a free meal.
She's just taken what she can get and
she's getting a show to come out to my
show. One of the best fucking
comedians in the country. You like Dad,
I'm talking shit. It's football Sunday
and I'm a plus. I'm reading the ric Flair,
the best comic on the
biggest hill. Um, anyways,
our Bob gets upset and
determines that no one has ever,
or will ever be able to please any female
code for why should he even make an
effort to make his wife happy in their
marriage? That's not code for that.
That's how you read into it.
You've never met Bob.
You've made all kinds of assumptions
here. Poor, poor Bob. Bob's do.
Sherry becomes a crystal,
becomes crystal clear when he is,
when he says something to the effect of
this whole night out was supposed to be
about her.
This is a,
this is classic male privilege wankery
but I realized this is hard for you and
Bob to see. So I'm here to help.
Um, I'll try to make it simple.
When you piss off your wife bringing her
along to a show you already wanted to
go to and that she is
only mildly interested in.
Then being a little,
scroll them about it when she's is
underwhelmed by the fact that you are
actually making an effort
to go out with her,
which is what you should have been doing
as a matter of course is not the way to
go. Oh my God. I mean
the arrogance in this,
I love people who are arrogant and they're
calling you out for being arrogant,
bringing her to a show.
Do you understand? Like,
I'm going to stop being a jerk here
because maybe I can actually convince a
couple of women. Do you understand
what it takes this, this will actually,
you know,
I've been generalizing.
There are women out there who understand
what it takes to become successful and
I guarantee you most of them are not in
relationships and they have a difficult
time being in relationships.
You know?
Because the guy that with wants to go
home and play fucking footsie or once her
around and doesn't understand that these
are the years where she has to bust our
ass to get where the fuck
she's going to be. You know?
Yeah.
So Lady, both of you guys
are a hundred percent wrong.
I could see if this guy was
out drinking with his buddies,
if this guy was out fucking around on
her or if he was just sitting there
staring at the TV watching football and
that paying attention to her when he
brings her out.
Yeah.
Then I could see that he should have some
sort of mini all about you wedding day
for her. Okay. But if this guy is
busting his ass, if fucking work,
okay, he's not going out
having a good time either.
So he should be allowed to
have some sort of enjoyment.
You don't understand. He should
be able to enjoy some of the day,
some of the night also. And this another
thing that you haven't even brought up,
how much of the rent do you
think he's fucking pain?
I'd be willing to bet that
he's paying more than she is.
A lot of guys are in that situation too.
When you get this,
the adult child version of a
fucking woman, I'm telling you,
you women,
I'm telling you the tool who wrote
in your way out of line on this one.
I'm not even trying to be funny right now.
You're 100% in the fucking wrong here.
You're being selfish. Beyond fucking
selfish. This guy is at work.
He's busting his ass trying to get ahead.
Do you think this guy wants to
fucking work 60 hours a week?
Nobody dreams about doing that.
Why do you think he's doing that?
He's trying to become successful.
You know?
So the next time you're,
you know, I like I said,
if this guy had been fucking around
or if this guy had been sitting there
watching you know,
sports and not paying attention to you
and hadn't given you a compliment since
you could fucking remember. Yeah, then I
could understand, you know what I mean?
Taking you to the whatever
the fuck you wanted to go to,
but for you to sit there and this
guy spends his hard on fucking money,
takes you out to dinner.
Okay.
Which you got understand is not standard.
And your home,
how fucking spoiled to you that you
think that that is step is standard.
I got the fucking hiccups here. I'm
so God damn upset. Um, you guys are,
you guys are 100% wrong.
And if any brides out there,
one want to try to come out
and support these two girls,
I mean go for it because I
don't see how they're wrong.
This guy did nothing wrong.
He took her out to go see a show.
It's just in order to stand up,
comedy is not respected. It isn't.
If he took you out to see a Broadway
show or a fucking musical or are,
I guess that's the same thing.
I Dunno what,
I guess if he took you out for dinner
and a movie. I love that. Like,
like guys always have to show some
sort of imagination. It's standard.
It was just an imagination.
We like surprises and it's like,
when was the last time your girl actually
showed any fucking imagination when
they got you a shirt,
you know,
or some sports DVD you,
did
they ever really show any sort of fucking
imagination? I'll tell you who does.
My girl,
she actually showed some imagination
one year when I first met her,
she, I uh, I was playing drums, you know,
she knew I was in a drum. She knew I
loved them and she actually got me this,
this pair of drums.
She gave me a pair of drum sticks and
we'd only been going off for like a month.
So there was like that thing,
you can't get a really huge gift,
but you got to get him some, she got me
a pair of drum sticks and she had my,
my initials engraved on them. I never
even used them. I thought it was really,
it was unique. It was
loving everything, know,
and it didn't cost that much money
and it was totally fucking cool.
I wouldn't be like, well, you know
that's, you got to do that every birthday.
You know, surprise me like you
did with the drumsticks. Xx.
Spend a ton of fucking money to, you
know, I didn't know if that even fucking,
I think I started to make one point and
then I made another one in that one.
I'm so fucking annoyed by these.
These women, they're there.
They're out of their fucking minds.
You're out of your fucking minds.
Okay?
If the guy who wrote that email last
week don't listen to these fucking twats,
all right, you bought, you're out
there, you're busting your goddamn ass.
You have to sit down and you have to
explain to your wife or your girlfriend or
whatever the fuck she is.
What it takes to become successful
because I'm telling you,
you understand what it is you're doing.
What everybody else did in their
20s all those people out there,
you know the brides with the tramp
stamps and the guys with the tribal band
tattoo who are out there doing keg
stands and fucking everything that moves,
doing their best to catch herpes
every fucking weekend. Those people,
they wonder what happens when they get
to their thirties and their forties they
wonder what the fuck happened.
You know?
And they're looking at you like you're
a shithead. You know? Now the payoff is,
is usually when you become successful,
you end up renting a corvette at 41
having sort of a mini midlife crisis.
But I'm telling you,
I'd rather be me than those other
fucking dudes. I really would.
So you really need to explain to this
woman who looks at you busting your ass as
neglect, as, as being selfish.
It's just beyond me.
It's fucking beyond.
You're doing what you're supposed to be
doing as a man is a man is supposed to
work and he supposed to
provide for his family.
And what you are doing as you are laying
the groundwork for you to do that as
best as you possibly can. And for
someone to say that that is selfish,
it's just fucking beyond me.
Okay. Let me ask you this.
When you went out that night,
how fucking tired were you?
How many times did you yawn from working
all fucking week? You know what I mean?
Yeah.
You know, aren't you allowed to go out
and have a good time with your girlfriend,
with a little bit of Shit that she enjoys?
A little bit of stuff that,
that you enjoy. Isn't that like
a fucking relationship? I mean,
am I out of my fucking mind here
anyways?
Um,
this is really just to
become a, a woman bashing thing.
This really just fucking tapped into.
This is another email I got bill.
This,
this got me so pissed off and I swear
the first thing that came to my mind was
wait until bill, here's this shit. Um, I
guess I listened to your show too much.
So here's the story.
He goes,
I went on my lunch break with the
female coworker today. And the,
the true mind of a female really shined.
I'm telling you a women,
you really got to chime in here and trash
guys, because this is really becoming,
this is like, like the guys this week
or Stanford and women are fucking USC.
But uh, whatever, watch Oprah. You always
went on that show. Here we go. First off,
I'm not interested in this female.
Uh, we are just friends. We have,
we've even talked about this and I
have explained to her and we agree,
nothing is happening
there. No problem. Uh,
so we go out to get a sandwich
and her ATM account is frozen.
She calls the bank and they
think something's wrong and
won't give her the money
till they talk tomorrow. Right there.
Fuck the banks. Right, exactly.
You can't even get your own fucking
money. Um, provided she's not overdrawn.
So here we go. So he goes, I would have
lent her the cash, but I was broke.
I offered to give her all the money,
all the money in my pocket,
about $2 and 50 cents in pocket change
that would at least bought her a coffee
mug. I already paid for my sandwich,
uh, when we found out about the ATM.
So she turns down that,
but asked me to drive her a few blocks
to go to the bank and I happily do, um,
that doesn't work and we
have to go back to work.
This is all during your lunch hour.
Um,
she asked me to borrow a credit card or
something to get food. I don't have any,
so she can't. So she calls back the job
in the ass. Another guy for five bucks.
He says, yes. Uh,
she then asked me for the two 50 she
turned down before. I said, sure,
now here is the fucking kicker.
So now this girl has seven 50.
She then tells me word for word.
Well, since I got five bucks,
now let me tell you something.
And with this fake grin on her
face trying to soften the blow,
actually she wasn't. She's going
into cut mode. Here she goes, uh,
if you were in this jam, I would
have offered you half of my sandwich,
but that's okay. I'm just saying.
And the guy said, I was floored.
I was like, Yo, first off,
you only said this after you got the money
because you knew how it might make me
feel and now you have my money
and don't need my sandwich.
So basically you just wanted to make me
feel shitty for not living up to your
standard of friendship. She
laughed it off and said, uh,
she was trying to offend me. She wasn't
trying to offend me and let it go.
Bullshit.
You called her out on a shit.
Notice how she waited
till she got your two 50,
and then did the little fucking
two point reversal on you.
Then she brings it up again and now I
realize she was really bothered by the
fact I didn't offer the sandwich I bought
with my last five bucks to my name.
Meanwhile, she, uh, she
has 400 bucks in the, uh,
they just won't give it to her tomorrow.
She will be fine.
I will still be broke yet she still
thinks I should have given her half of the
last sandwich I can for
a week till I get paid.
Um, the thing that gets me the
most is we work a labor job.
I'm always helping her lift and move
things because she herself brings up the
point. She is a girl, yet she talks all
the time about how men and women are, um,
are equal in the workplace and
she should be treated the same.
And this is in some dumb cunt. She went
to school for four years, got a degree,
changed your mind,
and now she's going back to get another
degree that will take her six more year,
years.
She reads and studies all day.
And I enjoy your conversations because
she smart. But at the end of the day,
I have learned she's still a woman and
she still feels she should somehow be
baby by other men simply because she
is a woman. I'm not sleeping with her.
We are just friends. Why do you
feel entitled to half of my last,
even if after I go out of my way,
um,
oh half of my sandwich.
Even if after I go out of my way
every way I can to help you. Exactly.
You went, you gave her every
last cent in your fucking pants.
You drove her down to the bank,
he drove her back to work.
This was all during
your fucking lunch hour.
You're lifting her boxes and all
that type of shit. I mean, I dunno.
I Dunno what to tell you.
I mean maybe you could have given her
half your fucking sandwich. I haven't,
I don't know what your relationship
is with her, but that's the classic,
you know, I could see if she
got the $5 out of the other guy,
you know and didn't take your two 50 but
she gets to five and then takes you to
50 and then brings it up.
You know what I mean?
I'm telling you do right then like I,
I like if someone did that to me,
I would be done with them.
I will be done with them.
I wouldn't tell him that it would
be done with them. What I would do,
it was I would wait for the next time
she needed me to lift something. Um,
I would do a country smile back to her and
be like, you know, if I was asking you,
I would, I would make sure that I would
live half the box with me, you know,
or whatever the fuck you want
to say. Um, anyways, he said,
thanks for letting me, uh,
event signed the Jewish dude.
Um, all right, let's see here.
I think that might be at a,
that it, that's it, right?
I think that is it. That is it for the
podcast. All right, well let me say it.
Let me state for the
record here. Um, I dunno,
after the second time reading that maybe
you could have given her half you st or
party his sandwich offered
her a bite. But uh, you know,
you spend all your fucking money,
then she finds out she's fucking broke.
But that is the typical female fucking
thing. Okay. Where Equal Rico rescue me,
rescue me, we're equal.
We're equal. Rescue me. They
basically, they ride that fence.
Okay.
And what most of them do is when
it's a good thing to be equal,
then your equal. And when it's a bad
thing to be equal, like, you know,
I to pick up something heavy then, then
it's like, oh, I'm just a girl, you know,
or dinner comes along and the check
comes along. Then I'm a female.
You should be a gentleman. I did a bit
about this a long fucking time ago. Um,
so basically they can, I mean, what
are they doing that's wrong there?
They're just trying to manipulate
the situation to their advantage.
All you have to do as a guy,
just be conscious of it and
call him out on this shit.
Um, you should have asked for
you to 50 back when she said, no,
you should have demonstrated
your strength as a man.
Tipped her upside down and
shook it out of her. Um,
that's it. That's it for the Monday
morning podcast. That was kind of dark.
That was kind of evils, kind of ugly. And
I anticipate a lot of emails, but, uh,
that's how the podcast goes sometimes.
And, uh, I know it wasn't on a cell phone,
but a go fuck yourself.
That's how I'm doing them.
That's how I'm going to continue
doing them. If you don't like it,
fucking go listen to the old ones. Go
listen to the old bunch of pricks. Um,
this week I'm going to be at the
Improv in Tempe, Arizona. All right.
I'm going to be there on Thursday,
Friday and Saturday. And uh,
there's been a little
switcheroo on my schedule.
I was supposed to be going to Seattle.
Yeah,
I was supposed to be going to
Seattle to play giggles comedy club,
but I'm unfortunately that
comedy club does not advertise.
So the only way I sell tickets is to go
on this one particular radio show and
they changed the format and
got rid of my hookup up there.
So there's no way for me to go into town
to let anybody know that I'm going to
be there. So the club owner would
just lose a ton of fucking money.
So like a class guy, I
switched out the date. Okay.
So basically I think I'm going to
be maybe doing Seattle in January.
So instead of going to
a giggles in Seattle,
I will be at the punchline in Sacramento,
California,
a punchline, Sacramento,
California on December 10th,
11th and 12th and 13th.
And uh,
the week before that I will be at
hilarity. He's in Cleveland. Um,
go to [inaudible] Dot Com B u r r for all
the dates and I can't believe I forgot
to mention this at the top of the podcast,
tickets are on sale for
a my neck stand up. Um,
one hour stand up,
a comedy special.
Um, it's going to be at the Fillmore
on December 17th in San Francisco,
California. If you would
like to come. Ah Shit,
I don't have any of the fucking
information. I am a goddamn worst.
Do I have the link?
I don't even have the link on my website.
I am the fucking worse.
Go to live nation.com.
That's where the tickets are being
sold. Just type in Bill Burr, um,
December 17th at the film or
you will be able to find it. Um,
or you can join my mailing list
because I know I sent out a, uh,
I sent out information about
that. I'm the worst. All right,
I'll have all the information
next week or I'll,
I'll be putting a bulletin up on my, uh,
my bill.com on my myspace page. Oh, on.
The other thing I forgot to tell
you is I have a uninformed radio.com
is the new website for the
uninformed show. I believe that's it.
Let me try and once again,
I'm the fucking worst.
I don't have any of the information live.
[inaudible] hang on a second.
Fucking voice is going way up here.
Hang on everybody who are fans of the
uninformed show with bill burr and Joe de
Rosa, everybody has asked
me for the longest times.
Where can I get the
shows? Uh, what did we do?
Okay.
Uninformed radio.com,
uninformed radio.com if you go there,
you can download all the shows
and they're going to be for free.
So if you'd like to hear more of me
running my fucking mouth, you can go.
They're uninformed radio dot column. That
is it all? You guys have a great week
to talk to you next Monday.
[inaudible] you been
[inaudible] well,
[inaudible] is your mind
the
[inaudible] Su
[inaudible]
[inaudible]. Yeah, so
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible].
Hello? Well, above whether the,
well,
we left
[inaudible]
do Tom based on that
[inaudible] Su
[inaudible] [inaudible]
yeah.